now we are having too much fun already
in the kitchen holidays coming too close
sadly but you know we've got the last
minute parties all the fun we've got to
talk about the party the actual the
atmosphere because it's all about food
so Diana joining us from Valley cheese
and wine uh she's a cheese Monger the
Wonder Woman of cheese that's right and
of course we have Nina from Forte Tapas
and if you haven't been oh my goodness
well she's the queen of caviar so this
is how you do New Year's Eve you've got
bubbles cheese caviar what else do you
need so talk to me about this how how
are you gonna have this kind of party at
home ladies what do we need to know so
Nina and I have been working together
for about a year and a half now um when
we combine forces we realize that we
really enjoyed each other's palettes and
the way that we create pairings is very
similar okay so we decided to a lot of
people use caviar and creme fresh as
sort of a delivery vehicle yeah which is
a dairy product all right so if you
extrapolate that mentality and bring it
to cheese we decided to pair caviar and
cheese together and then make the
perfect throttle with champagne I love
it okay so what should I start with as
far as my palette is concerned and what
should I be tasting what should I be
looking for so we're going to start with
just a traditional champagne this is a
grower producer champagne this is my
large Peugeot this is a brute it's a
female lead grower producer champagne
house and really traditional so just
have a sip of that champagne just to
warm your palette up this morning okay
get yourself used to how that's gonna
taste and smell
um really really gorgeous just classic
sort of brioche oh I love you know it's
a little bit of lemon on that and now
what we're going to do is we're going to
take that up a notch okay so go ahead
and take this piece of cheese this is
called Adare that's okay this one right
here Dari I'm gonna pull the dark let's
see
is a hard cheese from The Basque region
of France this is mixed milk sheep and
goat we've added some caviar on top of
this oh my God it actually really just
proliferate those flavor profiles you're
going to get some tartness and now
you're gonna chase it once you've chewed
it up a few times and you've got those
flavor profiles all over your palette
Chase it with I'm in heaven right now
this one the that one actually yep the
irreverse one okay yep so you're
actually what you're doing in here as
you're building the experience on your
palette you're warming yourself up with
the bubbly or adding the lady caviar and
then you're chasing again with the
bubbly to really round out that extra oh
my gosh okay as time winds down really
quick we gotta talk about caviar a lot
of people haven't tried caviar before
why is it so important what's special
about it oh my gosh it's so good so the
one that we have here that we're pairing
is the osetra and what I really love to
do and what we work with with Diana is
pairing it kind of in a unique way I
think caviar has been kind of an
intimidating uh product for a lot of her
absolutely a little stuffy so that's why
this is such a beautiful fun way to
enjoy caviar for the holidays or during
a special occasion oh my gosh okay and
really quick I know we have to wrap it
finally the last cheese that you have
here with the caviar is what it's a
triple cream Brie from the Ron Alps in
France super buttery um and then we
actually paired it with a Rose champagne
a lot of people are a little bit
hesitant about Rose Champagnes but they
are just as formidable this time of year
okay this one is from the south of
Champaign
um so yeah go ahead and take a sip of
that a little bit forward on the berry
notes because that fruits gets a little
warmer in the southern area oh my
goodness add that triple cranberry and
caviar and then Chase it again and
you've got a completely different
experience two different lines two
different cheeses same caviar but just
really illustrating and highlighting oh
my gosh how different sort of pairings
can change what happens on your palette
Valley Cheese and More I'm Diana thank
you so much down in Henderson go check
them out and get all this Forte Tapas in
the southwest Valley amazing amazing
food there very European but the caviar
I could I could spend 20 minutes for
sure we can geek out all day we're gonna
be right back ladies thank you so much
thank you